hi everyone um thank you for coming to
my talk my name is abhinav deshpande and
i'm a postdoc at the institute and for
quantum information and uh matter
at the california institute of
technology
today i'll be speaking about the
importance of the spectral gap in
estimating ground straightening energies
this work is jointly with alexey
gauschkov and will fulfillment who are
at um
the university of maine and in the
university of chicago respectively
and this is the archive reference
okay so let's uh jump in
um
this
is a talk about ground state energies uh
so i'll first define what that means
um
in physics a hamiltonian uh
it refers to an object um which is
essentially a function that
outputs energy given
as input a particular state or
configuration of the system uh you can
also think about it in terms of a cost
function
um
and the ground state uh
is just the minimum energy state of some
physical system
so it's whatever configuration that
minimizes the output energy
of the hamiltonian
and
studying ground states is
an activity that's very important in a
lot of fields some it has applications
for example in finance metaphysics high
energy physics even quantum chemistry
and of course in optimization because
optimization problems such as
constrained satisfaction problems can be
expressed in terms of
finding the traumatic energy of some
particular hamiltonian
so naturally this is a very important
question as to
studying how feasible this problem is
for general hamiltonians
and you can tackle this from the point
of view of both complexity theory which
tells you
when
uh instances are hard
and from the point of view of algorithms
which tell you when
uh some class of instances could be easy
okay and
uh so one
area that's born out of this is known as
hamiltonian complexity
where we typically study quantum
hamiltonians
um
and these you can think of today as
mostly being just some exponentially
large hermitian matrix
and
uh one of the important problems studied
in this field is the so-called local
hamiltonian problem
so in this problem we are given as input
a description of some n qubit
hamiltonian h
which is a sum of local terms h i
and
by local terms i mean that each term
acts and at most k qubits
um
[Music]
and by this i mean that attacks
non-trivially on k qubits and
acts as the identity on the
other n minus k qubits
uh and as output you want to
um find the ground state energy of this
uh hamiltonian h
or in other words just uh compute the
minimum eigenvalue of h
and you want to do this to let's say
inverse polynomial
so this was the first
base problem in this hamiltonian
complexity literature
and
i have showed that this problem is
qma hard
and qma is simply a quantum
generalization of the class np
so it means that
it's very unlikely that even quantum
computers can solve this problem in
general
so
more recent work due to feminine lin
showed that
it's p space hard to solve the same
problem
if you want the uh
error to be inverse exponential
and um
this is what we are calling the precise
regime
okay
um
yeah so let's look at what
algorithms have to tell us for this
problem
so we do know of uh efficient algorithms
for some special cases
uh such as
if you are assured that your qubits all
lie on the line with 1d connectivity
and you also know that there is a
spectral gap meaning that
um
the lowest
uh eigenvalue and the next lowest
eigenvalue are separated by some
constant amount
then
we do know of an efficient classical
algorithm to find the ground state
energy
similarly if we have
a
state with high overlap in the ground
state and also the existence of a
spectral gap
then there's a quantum algorithm to find
the ground state
uh but for other cases
uh like we mostly have a lot of
heuristics
and one one of
what one very popular heuristic
algorithm is the variation of quantum
eigen solver uh also called bqe
and
this has been widely successful and
it's fair to say that we don't
understand why
so one question is how do these
results fit in with the hardness results
that we saw earlier
so first off uh
the thing to observe is that the
original hardness result is uh too
general
because it just applies to arbitrary k
local hamiltonians
uh and
presumably the
hamiltonians that we are seeing in
nature uh for which
heuristic algorithms are performing well
have um possibly some more structure to
them
although um although this original
hardness result was too general uh like
you can still apply
you can still add on reasonable
restrictions to the hamiltonians
and um
still get some analogous hardness
results
such as
uh you can study q dates in one
dimension
uh or qubits in two dimensions
and translation invariant hamiltonians
and you can even restrict the
hamiltonian to consist of terms chosen
from a particular set
which gives you
all these named
models in physics such as the heisenberg
model on the bose hubbard model so on
and in all of these cases um we know so
far
uh analogous hardness results hold
so what we aim to do here is to identify
a structural property that sort of
bridges the two results that we know of
and
identifying these structural properties
would help us
void uh generic hardness results and
they help us identify features that can
be exploited by algorithms
okay
um
so our results concern
two ways of adding structure to the
local hamiltonian problem
so let's talk about uh what these are
okay the first structural property that
we will study is the spectral gap
so many interesting hamiltonians seem to
have a spectral gap and which i already
mentioned earlier it's the difference
between the smallest and the next
smallest eigen value
the spectral gap
is
often associated with nice properties
such as
existence of tensor network
representations
and
so-called entanglement area laws
which have been reversely proven in 1b
but conjectured for higher dimensions
it also implies easiness in various
senses
so
the
performance of the adiabatic algorithm
is decided by the minimum spectral gap
from the initial hamiltonian to the
final hamiltonian
and as i mentioned earlier it's also
easy to complete transit energies in 1d
on the hardness side though we do not
know much about how the spectral gap
affects the complexity
of the local hamiltonian problem
so
yeah even
if we have an inverse polynomial uh
spectral gap
we do not know if these aforementioned
hardness results uh
hold continue to fall
and our work is an initial piece of
evidence that
the the spectral gap makes the problem
easier in general
okay so let's see how
so we have a probable setting where the
spectral gap affects the complexity
and
the problem we are considering is to
compute the ground state energy
of a
delta gap hamiltonian
by whereby where i mean that the
spectral gap is at least delta
and we want to want to compute it to
inverse exponential precision
um
okay and
so when
delta equals 0
which means that
we are only assured that the spectral
gap is larger than zero which is just a
vacuous promise
then this problem is p space complete
and
this power is essentially stemming from
the fact that we are looking at inverse
exponential precision
okay so in this context we show that the
moment you add
an inverse polynomial spectral gap
the complexity of the problem
goes down from p space to p p
and
uh stated another way the spectral gap
probably makes the problem easier in the
setting uh and by that i mean the
setting of inverse exponential precision
or the precise second
and
of course this assumes that
p space is not equal to pp
which is i would say a fairly reasonable
assumption
um so
we think that this is weak evidence that
it's true in general
meaning that it's true
that meaning that the spectral gap
um makes the problem easier even outside
of the inverse exponential precision
setting
the second structural property we'll be
studying
is that of um
an existence of
classical descriptions of ground states
in physics we often want these non
trivial or numbing size descriptions of
ground states from which we can
efficiently compute
certain properties such as say the
energy or some local observable
and
it's not
uh obvious that
these descriptions exist
but for some cases they do
and some examples are say tensor network
descriptions from which you can compute
observables
another example
is say that of
an explicit description of a polynomial
sized quantum circuit that would prepare
the ground state uh now this
may not be
uh useful classically but
if you have a quantum computer then you
can
you know go ahead and prepare the ground
state and study its properties
so do such descriptions always exist for
local hamiltonians it's not clear a
priority
um
and yeah in if this if the answer turns
out to be yes then
that will imply that two
complexity classes are equal to one
another
so qma is just the analog of
uh
it's just a quantum analog of np
where merlin is a quantum witness and
arthur has a quantum computer
whereas qcma is another quantum
generalization of np
where the witness is classical
but the verifier is
still has a quantum computer
okay so
the difference between these two classes
qma and qcma
is essentially
all about whether
ground states of local hamiltonians
have efficient classical weaknesses for
them
and
given that this
question of qma versus qcma is so
interesting
no doubt there has been work uh done on
it before
so we know that there's some oracle
evidence that the two classes are
different
um
so yeah this is asking the question of
how rich is this set of states with
polynomial circuit complexity
and
for example whether it encompasses uh
the set of ground states of local
hamiltonians
and
there's not really a nice analog of this
question for np
because
every bit string
or every witness can just be prepared
with the depth one
circuit
that is aware of what the instances
um
yeah so quantumly
the ground state of some local
hamiltonian
could have
could need an exponentially long
quantum circuit to prepare it
okay
so our main result concerns this uh
our other main result concerns this
structural property
and
okay so we asked this question of how
important is the existence of classical
description
if you also have an inverse polynomial
spectral gap which is similar to
the question we asked earlier
and
again we
study this problem in the regime of
inverse exponential precision
and the answer is that it's not so
important
so in other words
if you have
an inverse polynomial spectral gap
and you have a classical description
the problem again is pp complete
so
again to phrase it another way
this extra promise of
lower circuit complexity made no
difference if you already had a spectral
gap
and this like there's a very suggestive
explanation
for this
previous result
um
so
here's a conjecture
which is that if you already
if you have a spectral gap of inverse
polynomial
uh in n let's say
then it implies that
you can have a polynomial sized circuit
to prepare some low energy state
and
this
conjecture is in fact a
a stronger version of result two in the
sense that it it would imply the result
um
so it also implies something stronger
meaning that
most it would say that most natural
hamiltonians have
short circuits to prepare the ground
states
and this is as i said earlier it's not
an obvious property
and this would explain why variational
algorithms
such as the vqe and other heuristic
algorithms seem to perform so well
because
the hamiltonians of interest
usually have at least the constant
spectral gap or an inverse for normal
spectrogram
and this conjecture would imply
that the two classes qma and qcma
uh in the presence of a spectral gap uh
coincide
and
in fact we have proved um
a version of this for like
um
for the case where you consider
inverse exponential position so that
adds this modifier precise to the two
clusters
okay uh so i'll just broadly describe um
our proof ideas
uh so for the pp up around in both cases
uh what we do is prepare a thermal state
at low enough temperature
and
a thermal state is just one given by the
gibbs distribution
so if you have
a constant spectral gap or even an
inverse polynomial spectral gap
this would ensure that
the thermal state has pretty good
overlap with the ground state
and
because
of this thermal state representation
you can write out the energy
in terms of a large sum
which can be computed in pp
uh as for the lower bound we modify this
uh construction of analog at all
uh which proved that
adiabatic quantum computing is universal
so we actually use another tool um
called the small penalty clock
construction
and
this is a technique
that we have come up with which
allows one to use perturbation theory
and
helps keep track of eigen values
and
helps you lower bound the spectral gap
of the
resulting hamiltonian that you get after
the reduction
so in other words it can be viewed as
spectral gap preserving production
okay
so to conclude um
here's a summary of what we know about
the local hamiltonian problem
when considering inverse exponential
additive error
in the case where the spectral gap
was only known to be
larger than or equal to b equal to zero
or in other words when there was no
uh when there was only a vacuous promise
on the spectral graph
um
the problem is p space complete when you
have a quantum witness
and np to the bp complete when you have
classical witness
and the addition of a spectral gap of
inverse polynomial
immediately reduces the complexity of
both cases to
pp
but in the classical case
the reduction of complexity is
you know not
uh more stringent in the sense that you
do not go even further below pp
um
so that's why that's what motivates our
conjecture that the spectral gap
already
implies the existence of all normal size
circuit
or a classical weakness
and this would explain why vqe
works so well in practice
so as for open questions
we can study the case of a constant
spectrogram it's not an inverse
polynomial spectral gap
and see whether the complexity can
reduce even further
um the non-precise regime or in other
words the regular
case of inverse polynomial additive
error as opposed to inverse exponential
additive error
is obviously a really important case
and
yeah there might be nice connections to
als and
tensor network representations in
physics
so okay here's a poll on the conjecture
uh which i again have rested studies
raised pre-stated here
which is that and
a spectral gap of inverse polynomial
implies a polynomial size circuit to
prepare some low energy state
um
i would like
you to vote on this conjecture
which you can
do by uh going to this link
so there's four options true false
undecided and not so interesting
uh so yeah if you go to this site
you will
see a poll here
and
yeah i'll take a moment there
okay and
in case you are curious
uh the results
as of the time of me giving the stop
from previous iterations of this talk
have been as follows
and with that i thank you for your
attention